[Applause]
America is getting chippy out there
right another attack on comma you saw
Dave Chappelle get attacked on stage
again war on comedians keeps going on
and I love this this is so America the
guy had a real knife inside of a fake
gun
[Laughter]
you want to sneak a knife in somewhere
hide it in a gun
our uh our new friend Madison carthorne
is back in the news you know
I don't know if you're familiar with
this guy he's kind of new on the scene
he's very young under 30 I think one of
the youngest uh Republican or any
congressman
and uh Christian conservative
keeps getting caught
doing things that don't seem exactly
Christian conservative the late
we talked about it last week this week
There's a new video out of him uh naked
uh
straddling another man's face and
thrusting his pelvis into it
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
the
uh
the PornHub title was Republican [ __ ]
face [ __ ] face
and
he said
Madison already comment on this I'm not
joking he said he was just trying to be
funny
there's a picture of him in women's
lingerie women's underwear trying to be
funny he said it was a joke then last
week we had the video where he was in
the car
and he's saying I want to feel the
passion and another guy is grabbing his
dick joke he said it was just a joke
now we have him skull [ __ ] a guy on
tape and again I'm joking
I mean
it's infinite ways you can create a joke
his is always what if I was gay that's
that's I tell you
I gotta say
communicate this guy really commits to
the bit you know what I'm saying
I'm not saying he is gay at all I'm just
saying in Florida they're not allowed to
discuss him in school now